fox news is learning exclusively that
the largest conservative caucus
in the house is now calling on their
state governors to send national guard
troops or law enforcement to the
southern border
immediately south dakota governor
christie gnome answering that call by
sending 50 national guards men and women
to texas
gnomes says the biden administration has
failed
in the most basic duty of the federal
government keeping the american people
safe
the border is a national security crisis
which requires the kind of sustained
response
only the national guard can provide end
quote
congressman chip roy republican from
texas is in the faulkner focus
joining me now from edinburg texas and
the rio grande valley
congressman great to have you on the
program first of all tell me what you
anticipate to show
the former president trump today
well good morning harris always great to
be on your show i wish unfortunately
this is a circumstance where we're now
facing an existential
crisis here in texas and so we're down
here and i'm glad to see my friend
michael cloud on there he's one of the
best
members of congress but look from wuhan
to juarez the democrats have declared
war on the truth and that's the reality
they
refuse to actually acknowledge what's
going on we saw vice president kamala
harris
do a photo op trip enroute to los
angeles for a few hours pit stopping in
el paso
literally missing the mark by 750 miles
she
landed 750 miles away from right here
macau on the epicenter of the crisis
that was created by the bible
administration
where you just showed the numbers we've
had 700 000 apprehensions through may
we'll get the june numbers soon they
will be horrific but that's not
really the story the story is that the
cartels have operational control of our
border from the gulf of mexico
to big ben and the democratic party and
the current leaders in the white house
refuse to do their duty to secure the
border of the united states leaving
texas exposed
in danger our children facing the
horrors of an opioid epidemic
fentanyl up 800 percent in texas so
governor abbott is stepping into the
breach
governor desantis led the way you're
seeing other governors step in
and president trump who actually did his
job to secure the border
and it shows the compassion of wanting
to demonstrate that he
recognizes what's going on in texas is
coming here to mcallen where the current
administration
refuses to come you mentioned fentanyl
and i want to put something up on the
screen
because it is eye-popping the numbers
fentanyl seizures at the el paso sector
surged
4 000 percent over the past three years
a whopping 41 pound seed so far
in 2021 it's only the end of june
congressman as you prepare for this
visit it's still my understanding
through some members of congress and
among republicans
that the former vice president never
invited republican
lawmakers to be with her when she went
to el paso now a more important
epicenter if you will of this crisis a
former president
says yes come with me what again will
you show him that maybe he hasn't seen
in a few years since he's been there
well i think what the president's going
to see is the truth he's going to see
the truth from the department of public
safety of texas he's going to talk to
the governor
the attorney general members of congress
who actually know the truth who have
been visiting
with the ranchers down here getting
overrun the towns that we represent
dealing with high speed chases the
teachers the people in schools
that are seeing now an opioid opioid
epidemic as you just talked about with
the massive increase in fentanyl
we're seeing literally thousands of
americans dying because of what's
happening at our border in the southwest
border
and rhonda santos when he sent support
to texas and we're grateful for it god
bless him
he did it in part to help us but also
doing his duty as governor of florida
because he recognizes that the drugs
coming into florida
hurting his people are coming through
the southwest border it is the first
duty
of the government to secure your borders
and defend a sovereign nation
and yet president biden and kamala
harris refuse to do that
so i'm anticipating having a
conversation with president trump
about all of the great things he was
doing but now looking forward what do we
need to do now
states need help texas is supporting uh
securing our own border and states are
coming in to help us
and that's what we need right now the
president's going to help shine a light
on it while it's being ignored in the
current white house
i want to get to this a new draft the
house homeland security budget
would slash funding for customs and
border protection by about 1 billion
dollars
from last year and house minority leader
kevin mccarthy is responding
saying this quote house democrats are
now applying their socialist
ideology to defund the police to the
border
by advancing legislation to defund our
border and immigration law enforcement
and what is your reaction to that
congressman roy
well it's absolutely appalling i have
great friends who work with border
patrol
they are great folks who have been on
the front lines had 8 000 of them who
were infected with the
virus with the coronavirus we've had i
think 39 to 40 who have died from the
virus
they were slow to get the resources they
needed now you've got democrats
cutting their budget when frankly they
are overwhelmed
we got 40 of them being taken off the
line to come to processing centers in
mcallen processing thousands of people
because of the democrats incompetence
and now we've got wide open borders
between the ports of entry now they're
going to slash their budget
i introduced an amendment yesterday to
cut all earmarks
all 5.7 billion dollars of 1400 earmarks
and take that money and bring it down to
the border to fund the wall
i'm happy to take that money and fund
border patrol or the wall but we need to
actually do our job and secure the
border
we will follow the trail on that i mean
i can't imagine what kind of response
that will get among democrats that's
like shaking the apples out of the trees
let me move forward house republicans
held their own hearing on the origins of
covet 19 yesterday and house speaker
nancy pelosi of course refusing to hold
a bipartisan hearing
only people from our own party so
republicans got together and they're
also
urging the house to pass a bill
declassifying all intel on the wuhan lab
at the center of the covid controversy
the evidence continues mounting that
this was a man-made disaster
that started in the wuhan lab
if that is the case then it might
be considered dramatically worse than
chernobyl
in short china lied the world health
organization complied
and people died those responsible for
the deaths of 600 000 americans must be
held accountable
i believe it's time to completely
dismiss the wet market as a source of
the outbreak
in fact i would say this is a diversion
by the ccp
and all roads point to the lab
congressman we're all starved for the
truth over this i mean this is as you
point
just among the border patrol the deaths
but across the nation so many people six
hundred thousand
it doesn't seem like democrats are as
hungry for the truth or do they just see
it differently or what
well as i said i think the democrats
have declared a war on the truth it's
all about whatever is
important for their own uh political
purposes and and frankly it's cynical
what we've seen occurring in in china is
appalling
and you know a year and a half change
ago 15 months ago some of us were
raising these issues these questions
uh and frankly they were kind of swept
aside by our democratic colleagues but
also importantly swept aside by dr fauci
who's been elevated by some as some sort
of you know uh you know almost like a
god-like status in his covers of
magazines
but now we see in the email traffic of
dr fauci how much there was really
knowledge about what was going on in
china
we had state department officials two
three years ago that were raising up
alarm bells about what was going on in
the
institute in the wuhan institute of
virology these are the important things
we need to focus on and it's germaine to
the border because title 42
democrats are getting read ready to get
rid of title 42
which is our one thing we can do to hold
off 60 percent of those coming across
the river
so we need to do our job congressman roy
and you'll be doing your job
at the border with former president
trump today thank you for giving us a
preview
and hitting so many topics with me i'll
see you soon
thank you harris god bless god bless you
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now